Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that you
can call if you'd like to make your presence
known. That number is 2192. David P Here is a
caller with a very interesting question about
Trump's fate as a sex offender. On the basis
of the finding against him in the Jean Carol
sexual assault and defamation trial yesterday.
Speaker 2: Yes, David, this is Alan calling from
Texas. And I was just wondering, will Donald Trump
be forced to register on the sex offender website
as he was convicted of? What was it sexual
battery or saw with the aging Carol case?
Could you let us know? Thank you.
Speaker 1: The answer is no. Trump
will not have to register as a sex offender. So
I checked in with a couple lawyer friends today,
and this was my instinct. The sex offender
registry is for people found criminally liable.
Criminally liable. And because Trump was found,
I'm sorry, criminally guilty, because Trump was
found civilly liable as a civil judgment, a
monetary judgment. The standard of proof is
different, and it does not require registering as
a sex offender. Now, it is true that sex offender
registration laws vary by state, and every
lawyer I spoke to very lawyerly said to me,
generally speaking, civil liability in sexual
assault does not confer state sex offender
registry, but it's possible there's some state
where the laws differ because of the laws on
this stuff do differ from state to state. But I
was not able to find any state in which you are
required to register as a sex offender. If you're
found civilly liable for sexual assault. It's
usually pretty specific. It's you must register as
a sex offender if you are criminally convicted of
specific offenses. Usually rape is listed sexual
assault, child molestation, child molestation,
child porn charges are often in there, etc.. I
know that you're not supposed to call it child
porn, but I think everybody knows what I'm talking
about. The civil judgment question theoretically
could depend on state law. It appears as
though states could require that those found
civilly liable for similar actions be required to
register. But the belief of every attorney I spoke
to today is that there is no state that currently
has that requirement. So Trump, so far as I know,
will not have to register as a sex offender on the
basis of this finding. We have such a great bonus
show for you today, although many of the stories
are sort of sad stories and disturbing stories.
The gunman who killed eight at the Texas
shopping mall over the weekend, we now know
had neo-Nazi ideation and neo-Nazi tattoos.
Still, this isn't stopping some on the right
from saying it was a setup, it was a
false flag or whatever the case may be.
Of course, there's no evidence of that. There's
evidence that he was a neo-Nazi, although police
are still searching for the specific motivation
in going to that mall on that day. I think it's
fair to say he was a neo-Nazi. We don't yet
necessarily know the motivation, although we
can speculate. But let's try not to speculate and
go with what we know. So we're going to talk about
that on the bonus show today. Secondly, this seems
to happen again and again and again. One of these
anti grooming crusaders, he's a Republican, of
course, from Texas. He is now resigned because
of sexual misconduct he was involved in with a
teenage staffer or aide, I think they call them.
Yet again, yet again. And lastly, the subway crime
debate has been revived in New York City because
of this horrible choking death that took place. I
have so much experience with the New York subway
and I've seen it change to some degree over the
years. I will weigh in with my experiences on the
subway as well as a white looking guy. Right.
I think it's fair to say. Sure. I'm a Hispanic
immigrant from Argentina, but I present like a
white guy, a boring white guy. And I know that
that may be a factor in my experiences versus the
experiences of others on the New York subway. So
we'll talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Please sign up for the
bonus show, folks. It really is great.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Okay. I mean, we do make money
on the bonus show, but it also it really is great.
And we'll talk about all of these stories today
you can sign up at join Packman dot com. I believe
our normal membership rates are so reasonable
so reasonable. But if you'd like a discount,
it's not means tested. It's available to whoever
wants it. Use the coupon code indicted and you'll
save roughly 50%. All right, everybody, see
you in a few on the bonus. So we're back to.